jobs day I see you down there put a
thumbs up in the camera if you're a
Muslim jobs day you're a
Muslim thumbs up if you're a Muslim
no yes okay you look
confused I can't hear you though but
I'll find out when I bring you up couple
more here and then we'll move on back up
over to
YouTube all right hash is
back hey what's going on what's up man
you a
Muslim yes I am yes I am all right
welcome to the panel my
friend so I I'm I'm Muslim but I I don't
know too much about Christianity right
like I just want to understand the
Trinity concept well before we
understand the Trinity concept we got to
start with the simple things first Jesus
being a Muslim do you believe
that yeah from our Paradigm in our books
that that's what it's mentioned yeah
yeah but is that is that the is that the
TRU
yeah that that's what's mentioned and
inside certain Biblical verses there
could be a narrative that he was praying
to the father he was essentially is
Allah the father asking father for the
Forgiveness around the end of his life I
think he he didn't ask for forgiveness
he said father forgive them for they
know not what they do but yeah father
forgive them yeah is Allah is Allah the
father of
Jesus well in a term of endearment
fashion I guess God is the father of all
because he created because the father is
the creator right so in a sense God is
the father of all in the sense even
animals is Allah a
nurturer what do you mean by that
defined nurture is he a nurturer does he
take care and nurture and you know raise
up of course yes he provides sustenance
for living creatures do mothers do that
do mothers nurture and provide
sustenance for living for their children
yeah mothers do as well in fact a mother
and father's love from Islamic Paradigm
is a reflection of the F the love of God
so would you say so would you say that
Allah is also can be said that he's like
a he's a mother in in some sense in the
sense that he's a nurturer caretaker
thing is the thing is yes he can be but
you also have to come at it from an
understanding that the the father is a
disciplinarian and Jesus role also so to
come on Earth was I would assume to
discipline his people and put them on
the right path look I mean I'm coming at
it from a general understanding as well
right like the thing that I don't
understand is how a human can be looked
at as God and the thing that and and the
thing that I don't understand is how the
Messiah can be looked at as a Muslim
when he existed 600 years prior and
taught everything that is contrary to
hold on one second and taught everything
contrary to is Islam like for example if
I mean I mean this is this is uh it's
2024 now so Islam is like ever changing
so we're we're we're starting to get
Muslims now like at first it was an
absolute no no to say that Allah was a
father now Muslims are kind of saying
that he's a father now and then and then
you know it was absolute no no that he's
a mother but now Muslims are coming out
and saying that he's a mother of a
father like he birthed us no no you're
saying you're saying in in some sense
yeah in a metaphorical right in the
sense that he is you know the the the
source or Creator right of all things
you're saying that he's the father in
that way is that many that would mean
that would mean that he's a mother in
the way that he nurtures and Care takes
like he's he has he's a mother as well
of course there the both of those
qualities and characteristics of the
both genders are actually essentially a
reflection of God's love to his people
right like if you would assume there's
no real gender to God God is a being of
our of our comprehension can we agree
upon that yeah I agree with you so I I
want to read inance why was Jesus I want
to read I want to read a Quran verse I'm
just curious I want to read a Quran
verse to you to see to see if you agree
with the what the Quran says
okay are you gonna pull up the verse
where it says that God can indeed have a
child or essentially but he just it's
above his magesty is that the verse
you're going to pull up um no the verse
that I'm going to pull up says that that
he doesn't have any children in any
way and uh you can only be his slave you
can't be his son not even
metaphorical so it says here Chapter 19
Verse 93 there is none you're absolutely
correct actually you are actually
absolutely correct that in the sense of
slave right what is a slave right
somebody who abides by the ruling of the
master I mean let's keep it a buck we
have slavery present in modern day times
as well is there a difference between a
slave and a son I'm sorry what is there
a difference between a slave and a son
and here's the here's the difference in
understanding my father also in the
sense like as a even in like uh loving
and Dearing ways sometimes like oh
you're my slave you have to do what I
what I tell you please right no he does
I swear to God all right I'll ask let me
just ask this is there a difference
between a Slave
and a
son well in in a sense I think there is
a difference but there's also not right
so like for so for for for example for
example a SL a son can be a slave to his
parents right absolutely right um but so
every son is a servant right is a slave
yes but not every slave is is a son can
we agree
there yes okay so there's a genuine
difference there's a genuine difference
so a son is more than a slave he's not
merely a slave he is a son or a daughter
is a daughter while a slave who is not a
son is merely a slave that's it right
yes okay yes so this is what the Quran
says it says there is none in the
heavens or the Earth that can come to
Allah
except as a
slave you can't come to him as a son or
a daughter metaphorically literally
nothing well that that doesn't
contradict my my point of view though
because my my point of view is that
regardless yes we might not be the
literal sons of God and that's that's
not the definition he's going for in
this verse slave in a sense is the
obedient followers yeah but according to
this can you come to him as a
son well okay then maybe I've made a
maybe I've made a error and I don't
think that maybe we can always be in the
sense of in a son then well I I I I
respect your honesty man as long as we
are honest with what the text says
islamically you cannot be a deemed a son
of Allah in any way shape or form bro
can it be used as a term of endearment
nope in the Biblical context oh in the
biblical cont see now now you're
switching okay I'm curious yeah yeah so
biblically there's many ways that there
are children of God many different
senses so yes to answer your question
biblically yes but islamically no you
can't all right okay so what about a
prophet can a prophet be looked at as
like higher than just a slave is there
like Prophet prophets are deemed as sons
of God in God's eyes yes okay so that
would explain a little bit more in the
sense of the position that Jesus can a
Son of God well let's address this let's
let's address this because Jesus like I
told you there's different senses in
which
there are son and father relationship
with uh with God in the Bible okay
Jesus's son and father relationship is
different in the prophets Jesus is the
begotten Son of God the prophets are not
okay they're adopted as his sons what is
begot hold on we'll get to there in a
second so the fact that islamically you
cannot be a son of Allah in any way
shape or form the fact that Jesus is
saying that he is the Son of God and God
is his father
means he's not a Muslim
right does he say that exactly in the
biblical like in the Bible yeah he
literally says I am the Son of God
that's John
10:36 and you're saying because of the
understanding that he is referred to as
the begotten son he's not used no I'm
saying the fact that he refers to
himself as son at all in any sense takes
him out of the fold of Islam because
islamically you cannot be a son of Allah
in any
sense
but that prophets can be the Son of God
so so either you're playing with me
either you're playing with me or you're
not listening so I'm maybe maybe I
didn't catch that okay I'm gonna say it
again I'm gonna say it again everybody
else is catching it but for for some
reason it's like going over here I'm
gonna say one last time if you don't get
this then I'mma just I'mma deem that
you're playing with me and I'm gonna
move on so I said very
clearly biblically you can have
different senses of sons of God
islamically you have no sense in which
you can be a Son of God it doesn't work
islamically biblically yes islamically
no those are two different things you
understand what I'm
saying I I hear what you're saying okay
so if Jesus is referring to himself as
the son of God does that line up with
what the Quran just says that you can
only be his slave does that line up with
that well in your Paradigm no it doesn't
right but then again we don't really
completely look at the Bible and didn't
say my Paradigm don't don't do that
don't say in your Paradigm my don't do
that we're speak we're just looking at
it for what it is man what is wrong with
you guys we're looking at it for what it
is just answer the question Straight
Ahead straight away when Jesus says he's
the son of God and Allah says you can
only be a slave not a son when Jesus
says he's the son of God does that line
up with what Allah just said in the
Quran
oops what is happened what I'm also
trying to get to the understanding is
that you're kind of glazing over the
fact that God does use certain
narratives where he Associates himself
to mother or father in the in the
quranic text where where does he do that
where does he do that give me for
example when he when he mentions that he
he has the love he has 77 times more
love than a a mother for his where does
he say that he's a mother where does he
say he's a mother not that it says that
he's a mother but he has more love than
a mother so so it doesn't so he never
refers to himself as a mother or a
father so I'mma ask it one last time
when Jesus says he's the son of God and
the Quran says no one can be a Son of
God you can only be a slave does that
line up does what Jesus say being the
Son of God does it line up with what the
Quran just said well in the Bible it
does not but again we have to come back
to the understanding that the Bible has
been corrupted so all now the Bible's
been corrupted so before we get there
can we then agree that biblically Jesus
is not a Muslim right
well for again as I mentioned from the
beginning right from the Muslim Paradigm
I don't care about no I don't care about
a Muslim parad I just asked you
biblically biblically Jesus is not a
Muslim right yeah I mean well biblically
then he's not but then there's also
points in the Bible where he is
prostrating to the ground prostrating to
who prostrating to who to the father so
is he if he's prostrating to his father
is he a
Muslim well in the sense of not that I'm
going to say he was praying the same way
that we pray or com thanks for coming
get out of
here thanks for coming
man hello what's up my
brother how you doing old friend I'm
pretty good man pretty good just work it
through the Knuckleheads what took you
so long to get
here uh I'm at the airport actually oh
man so you just left me here to deal
with the the type of people I'm dealing
with today just cuz you got to be at the
airport no I feel you
bro crazy what is the
topic Jesus is a Muslim or you know
anything Allah is not God Quran is false
yes uh I'm not going to take too much of
your time but I would say yes do you
have
any evidence to prove otherwise prove
otherwise that Jesus is a
Muslim yeah wasn't a Muslim what's your
evidence that he
was well I believe the Quran is the word
of God so I don't that doesn't make make
him a Muslim how how do you what does
the Quran give you as an evidence that
Jesus was a Muslim that it got this
claim
right okay uh could I use the fact that
the Bible is unreliable as a source of
evidence or you can say that I and then
I'll show you how you don't believe that
yeah um actually can I point out
something uh I saw a video of you
and and it was regarding the the age of
Isaiah aiah when he became king
yeah are you switching topics right now
no no same topic same topic um I'll just
uh give a summary of what happened in
the video you andan spoke if I you Andy
me okay I was there what what does this
have to do with what does me my
conversation with lman have to do with
anything about Jesus being a Muslim bro
you said the Bible is has no
contradictions so what does that have to
do with Jesus being a
Muslim yeah you did say you accept
evidence if I provide evidence that the
Bible is unreliable you said you would
accept it as evidence okay so you said
that the Bible is
unreliable and I said you can use that
and I would show you otherwise that you
don't believe that I'll show you that
you believe the Bible is reliable would
you like to would you like to just see
that yeah I would what language did
Jesus
speak um Islam doesn't provide evidence
I know Islam doesn't provide it but what
language does he speak I would assume
Aramaic through
historical
accounts I'm not sure through historical
accounts What language
Aramaic what historical accounts tell
you that he spoke
Aramaic secular on the teachers in
school what what secular account where
do they get this from because they're
not primary
sources there is one source that isn't
from any Christian uh yeah what what is
that I forgot the name of that Source
but there is there is nothing unless
they're pulling from unless they're
pulling from a Christian
Source I'm pretty sure it wasn't a
Christian so what was it
but you correct me then I can look it up
and maybe talk oh yeah I just after our
conversation yesterday I realized you're
not going to have Tik Tok they're
banning It in America brother I I'm a
YouTuber yeah I see I followed you on
YouTube last night when I realized it
yeah I got I'm I'm Live on YouTube right
now we have 3,200 people in
there God damn yeah I'm I'm a YouTuber
I'm not a Tik tocker glory to
God can you prove to me
that that
Islam uh says the Bible is relable
brother you said Jesus spoke Aramaic you
said you get it from historical sources
what historical sources tell you spoke
fine are the Christian sources what
Christian
sources your
Jud Jude Christian scholarship your old
Scholars where did they get Christians
yeah where did they get it
from I would assume the
disciples exactly and what did the
disciples write where where do the
disciples say that he spoke
Aramaic I don't know if you're so close
you're so close it's it's in the Bible
bro Us in the Bible many
okay well go ahead so you
have the New Testament is where you get
that Jesus spoke Aramaic where you get
the historical evidence of the language
of Jesus so even you believe that the
Bible is reliable and it offers reliable
historical information on the life of
Jesus the Bible is the only evidence for
Christianity Testament the Bible is the
primary evidence not the only it's the
primary evidence so there are other
sources of evidence there
aren't yes in yes but as far as as far
as what we know about Jesus the New
Testament that's the primary that's the
primary source of information that's the
only source of information when we get
about his language like for sure with
with other texts you'll get that you
you'll you'll get the
uh you you'll get that Jesus lived in
first century Judea which Within by
probability you'll say well he might
have spoke Aramaic you wouldn't know
that for sure just so they just
acknowledge his existence they
acknowledge his existence and they
acknowledge his crucifixion and the
claims about him that he that they said
that he did Miracles Christians
worshiped him and y y
y right so that's what we have man so
the Bible is reliable according to
you no I'm just presenting evidence that
I've had Fu anything well this is where
we're at you say that Jesus spoke
Aramaic that comes from the Bible fine
the argument I can put the argument to
to an end by just using the
linguistic sense as in the word Muslim
it is it doesn't come from Arabic it it
also exists in Hebrew and uh no it
doesn't it just means to
submit he doesn't no I don't know who
told you that have a Jewish Orthodox
neighbor and needs this it exists I
don't care what your Jewish Orthodox
neighbor
says it doesn't exist in other languages
other than Arabic it's not in the
Bible I never said it's in the Bible no
okay I said it's a word in other
semantic languages well I don't know
just from linguistic
standpoint so what what he's not a
Muslim no from a linguistic standpoint C
can you can you be can you be a Muslim
and believe that you're the son of God
and the judge and Judgment Day and all
that kind of
stuff that's that's a
theological error has nothing to do with
the linguistic it has nothing to do with
being a Muslim being a Muslim has
nothing to do with theology you can be
an atheist and be a
Muslim to submit Jesus the devil submits
to God did he he's not a
Muslim excuse me you said the devil
submitted to God when
yeah
when he doesn't submit to God in your
Bible he's rebellious he's the
enemy well the does the devil doesn't do
anything without God's permission in
Islam I'm not going to say anything
about your religion but no I I I feel
you I feel you on that so is the devil a
Muslim since he submits to
God
linguistically the English the English
language is weird he's not a disbelieve
he believes in God but is he does he
submit to
him yes so is he a Muslim
linguistically say say say say say
you're he you
know I'm
not um look being a Muslim is the
headache Somali because you have to do
this you're a thinker we've talked you
know so you know I like you you're a
thinker you don't sit in like stupidity
you realize
things the headache is when the logic
you know surpasses Islam it's it it it
forces you to think Beyond it that's
where the headache comes from Hold Up
Hold goad so so devil Satan doesn't
submit to God in Christianity no I'll go
with you yeah yeah because he he can't
do anything outside of what is allowed
but at the same time he is also a he's
the enemy of God right rebellious so in
a in a way there is there is a
submission because he can't do he's
powerless so you know but I wouldn't say
that that makes him a Believer or a
Muslim that's when when I say Muslim it
can either mean someone who follows the
prophet Muhammad or and his religion or
it can mean someone who submits to the
most high the one monotheistic God okay
whether he believes yeah so you believe
that Satan submits to the most high God
monotheistic God so linguistically is he
a
Muslim uh it doesn't have any value but
yes Satan is a Muslim we're in 2024 2024
mus the term it has no
value oh so Muslim means Muslim no him
being linguistically someone who submits
to God is of no value because he's
rebellious and he's
so what you're saying is that the word
Muslim means nothing then it means
nothing it has no value out it has no
value you you can submit to the most
high God be considered a Muslim and it
means nothing it has absolutely no value
yes no yes or no does SAT to submit to
God yes or no in Christianity to an
extent
yeah and the
word you can you can look it up yourself
if you want but the word Muslim exists
in the language Hebrew I don't know
about never I've never seen I've never
seen it but I can look it up and then
send it then comment it in your live but
that that still wouldn't mean anything
to
me
no
so are we are we sticking with Satan
being a Muslim but it just means nothing
no no no we're not I'm not going down
that path okay so Satan is not a Muslim
even though he submits right
my guy this is not a fun
conversation why do you think I like
this
topic it's fun for me f f
fine
uh actually no I was going to say
something from the Quran but you don't
care about the Quran I like you thinking
before you speak bro seriously people
don't do that
often I'm not going to take too much of
your time you can you can take
no some no you could stay as long as you
want
Habibi you could stay as long as you
want man the as long as you keep
thinking and keep progressing because
the way that you're going is going to be
out of Islam if you continue to be
honest and and a critical thinker it's
gonna be out of
hislam can we yeah that's not going to
happen we'll see can we agree that
historically Jesus is not a Muslim
objectively can we just agree with that
what do you mean by Muslim then Define
Muslim um one who submits to to and
believes in the concept of God of Allah
of Islam when when Jesus said my God and
your god what does he mean why'd you cut
his phrase in
half he says what do you mean cut I
didn't cut his phrase in half y he says
he says my father and your father my God
and your God that's the full phrase
what about the verse where he says no no
no no no no no no no stay right there
you brought up that verse no I'm just
giving you an example I don't no no I
you gave me an example a beautiful one
yeah but I'm giving you another
one don't no need for another example
Hab why is that why why not why not
because you brought a perfect one you
brought a perfect example where Jesus
says my God and your God
my father and your father is God the
most high is he the father of
Jesus in Christianity yes he is okay so
when you're referring to these Biblical
verses to try to show that Jesus somehow
was a Muslim let me ask you this no I
didn't what was the point of you
bringing up the verse where Jesus says
my God and your God my father and your
father what was the point of that verse
to to prove
you I don't have to take anything of
your Bible as evidence I can just
provide something to you and you need to
take it as empirical evidence Somali
what was the point of you bringing up
that verse in light of our
discussion why'd you bring it
up somal where you go come on man don't
pause on me when I ask a good question
man the momentum is high we hot right
now maybe he got a phone call either
he's checking something or he got a
phone
call but man far be it oh I lost him
yeah he probably got a phone call far be
it from
me
to take something out of context or
to hold the Muslim to the very verse
that they bring up to prove their point
far be it from
me excuse me your
majesties forgive my
insolence forgive it I beg
you let us be well
met and let us reignite our
acquaintance with logic
and intellectual
honesty let us be well met Brothers F